yeah i became muslim right that day
i try to tell me i shouldn't listen i'm
being brainwashed
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount
code salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum what happened today to
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this video before i
start i want to praise allah subhanahu
wa
the most merciful the most trust or
praise his glory and gratitude belong to
him
brother sister this is i came across a
very profound video
of a 60 year old american woman 60 year
old imagination for 60 years
not coming across islam in any way shape
or form or maybe here and there
hearing bad things about islam and you
happen to watch erturu
now after all is when it first came out
people told me to watch it i was like
if i get into this it's going to be a
lot of waste of time i understand it's
good for those who are not practicing
exceptionally
i'm saying i'm better than no one saying
that for those who are not pregnant i've
heard of got good news that people
started practicing and praying etc
that's brilliant and really good but for
me i thought uh like personally
like i [ __ ] do better things yeah
however for some people individuals who
are watching haram stuff or different
movies
this come from me yeah um i'm not going
to move this
perfect and there's some characters in
there that you shouldn't really take
from and in this reaction video there's
an interview with this very lady and
she's telling us
what led her to come to islam
it was air through but how let's get
straight into instrumental here we go
got it just look into it i think
over the generations it's just kind of
lost itself
islam and um
but yeah i just wish it was a less of a
me me society
and more of what i can do for society
[Music]
[Music]
i looked into it the details was about
it it intrigued me so i started watching
it
and the first episode i was very
interested i was stopping a lot to look
up some things
um but yeah i was very interested in it
i liked
i liked where it was going it was
history that i knew nothing about a
little life
to live a life back then to have such a
goal as they did
and to live a life like that back then
is just
very admirable what they did
some reason one day i just happened to
do a
search for is there a mosque close to my
area and um
there was just this little bitty house
and
so i went i went in they were shocked to
see me i think
but um yeah i became muslim right that
day
after this after the prayer
where i used to live that very very
christian
i tried discussing with her and she just
did everything in her power to try to
tell me i shouldn't listen
i'm being brainwashed and so i just i
i don't even do facebook anymore
before and i did not take that
medication anymore i think
waking up every morning and i thank him
again for giving me another day every
night when i go to sleep
isn't that profound brothers and sisters
isn't that amazing
now and i want to emphasize on what
she's watching now let's just the best
way to make money with amazon in 2021 i
don't want to make
money on amazon bro relax yourself sorry
guys about that
just imagine guys she's watching the
movie earth yeah now after
yes there's these historical facts in
there et cetera and these things did
happen et cetera
the build-up of the ottoman empire but
however a lot of it's fiction
yeah okay and and what i'm saying is
that the standards and the values that
they had no of course that is how israel
for example elders like
i'm kurdish from turkey and the respect
that we have for our elders and those
certain traditions are there of course
and this is derived from islam but
what i'm trying to get the point the
crusty is this she's watching a movie
yeah this movie's got historical facts
every now and then but
she is so moved by their justice by them
sticking up for justice
for their mercy for how they put their
religion before anything
like even there's a scene in there where
for example it has a scene where
there's a specific villain guy who's
caused so much havoc and killed that
tried to cross
him coming to islam and the guy is like
shocked is that brother i've done so
much harm to your family
and me accepting islam and this time
you're just totally forgetting and
forgiving and even though allah says
it's best to forgive
even if somebody doesn't come to islam
just because they come to islam
those values really resonate with people
and hit
home hard because she's saying we're
living in a society where it's all
me me me me and she's talking about
sharing you know talking about justice
upholding justice well allah says
stand up and speak up for justice even
if it's against yourself
these are the values as muslims we
should be known for that's in the movie
that's portrayed
if this this sister was looking at
muslims today do you really think she
would have come to islam
but what she saw there and was like wow
and that is the true islam
in the context of while they're carrying
this off and it comes back to a very
simple message
the prophet peace be upon him said i
came for nothing
nothing but to perfect good character
this woman didn't look and said
in the movie it doesn't talk much about
allah's tahit and his wonders in that
context
i'm trying to say yes there are some
elements to it she came because of the
character
she was like what makes these people so
beautiful what
what makes these people so having moral
values
and caring about others in such an
extent that she thought i need to look
into this
that is deep for those who come and see
tawheed is about talking about the
wonders of allah 24 7
and they think repeating like a robot
with algorithms
helps them this sister this woman came
to islam by looking at something
fictional then understanding what
islam really teaches she goes to a
mosque and accepts islam
isn't that powerful doesn't that tell us
that as muslims
we should let people see islam in us
rather than just
hear it from us with the way we hold up
for justice
yeah and not lie and have up the
best form of character like the prophet
peace be upon him that allah says in the
quran
once we do that then you will see
nations will come to islam
and one the most powerful thing we have
is the quran if we abide by that
the people would observe our actions and
they would see
this can be no other than but from a
high place
this action and behavior what it's
according to can be from no other
than a place that is from the one the
the creator
subhanallah she came through a movie el
toro
allah tell of guys how he wheels and i
know many people and people have
told me about people practicing their
religion communists and why because now
it's that connection with their religion
yes there are certain characters and
they have to be real as well yeah for
example
yeah um for example it that
they as far as i know many ulama in the
past have done
fear of him certain views he has here so
i'm not asking anybody to go
uh i'm actually saying outright do not
take yeah straight um yes i understand
in the movie it seems like
that's that's the movie there yeah we're
just talking about reality here
so there's some very very dangerous
views but however
in a nutshell brothers and sisters the
good of that movie
rather than staff outweighs it and this
sister
came to islam via that wow what does
that say
what does that say or upholding good
moral conduct honest being truthful not
lying
subhanallah these are the things and
today when we see muslims and i'll be
honest with you guys i'm dealing with a
court case an insurance claim fraud
fraudulent
case that's happening towards me i had a
little minor accident to a muslim
yeah there was accident there was a
dispute between us in the context where
it's a long story and i'm going to talk
about this because it's very important
i am going to court because they are
lying these are muslims
these are muslims i had two accidents
one of them this
was another muslim yeah okay and he had
no insurance and he lied
yeah and it caused me a lot of damage
yeah the second one he actually lied the
fraud claim that there were certain
people in the car
and they were hurt and i'm like yeah you
know there wasn't four people in the car
you know no one was
not injured nobody was injured it was
like a little accident smooth
and this is what i'm saying as a muslim
when i see another muslim doing that i'm
thinking wow subhanallah do you not
think you're going to stand in front of
allah
do you not think you're going to stand
in front of allah and the brothers
telling me to know about my dad
anyways do you get it i'm going to be
talking about this case once the
the once i go etc i'm going to be
dwelling into this case because it's so
important
to show how people are too busy about
the materialistic world
acclaim how are you going to stand in
front of allah under their judgment
lying
as muslims may allah protect us to be
honest and not lie oh i got hurt my knee
back
my back anyways until next time guys
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh